care international's senior humanitarian
advisor on gender and protection susie
madigan joins me now to discuss this um
we were just talking to ukrainian mp uh
a short while ago who said that she'd
been hearing first-hand accounts
of women who'd suffered abuse around the
areas of butcher and hosta mail
what a care international hearing
well i mean we know that sexual violence
in conflict is a is a major issue
globally from ukraine to afghanistan
democratic republic of congo so we are
extremely concerned about the
reports that we're hearing and obviously
would uh hope for investigations into
that um
very soon but also we we call on all
parties to the conflict to recognize and
respect international humanitarian law
even in
even in the case of war um there are
rules and um violations against
civilians civilians infrastructure um
needs to stop and needs to stop
immediately
so also crucially survivors of sexual
violence um which the of course will be
in ukraine as there are unfortunately in
conflicts across the world
those people who are the victims and
survivors of sexual sexual violence need
to be given support um very quickly as
well it's an immediate medical emergency
um and so immediately protect protection
measures need to need to get in and
people need to be
able to access medical services within
72 hours at least
and it's not just sexual violence inside
ukraine is it there's also the concern
about trafficking um i was down there on
the border with poland a few weeks ago
and it struck me how many of the women
coming across
were incredibly vulnerable they'd been
through a really traumatic time they
might have young kids with them a lot of
them just looked absolutely
shell-shocked and there are people that
will prey on them there
absolutely i mean there are there's a
range of um gender-based violence um if
we refer to it like that risks in
conflict and any time any type of
emergency so as soon as somebody becomes
reliant on other people for the basics
they need to survive
that makes them vulnerable and
unfortunately notwithstanding the
incredible outpouring of support that
we've seen from people on the border on
the borders unfortunately that there are
others who will take advantage of that
both from within the conflict um you
know theater of war itself and also yeah
in neighboring countries but also
domestic violence really increases um in
conflicts and emergencies and it's
something that's not always readily
recognized and this is because of
inequalities um amongst men and women in
society you know it starts with the
language it starts with attitudes and it
and the ultimate
expression of that is violence violence
against women and girls in particular
but of course sexual violence um you
know can occur um it can be perpetrated
against men and boys as well
unfortunately in conflict situations we
need to be aware of that
and the the violence the sexual violence
that is reported
absolute tip of the iceberg
some of the figures that i've seen that
you've provided uh show that in the
bosnian war for every reported rape
there were 15 to 25 unreported rapes do
you do you think that even now all those
years later when people
are much more open about talking about
these kind of things that that we'll
still see a huge number that go
unreported
well the problem is including that
figure um that was reported from
prosecutors within the um uh
international criminal you know in
yugoslavia
that is an estimate
and the problem this is one of the
problems with sexual violence that it is
vastly underreported and that's because
of people's fear of stigmatization risk
of reprisals often
if services and justice procedures
aren't actually in place if the rule of
law is not respected then people might
be concerned that they will go through
the trauma of reliving experiences
talking about it being known for for
that having happened happen to them and
yet they'll never have any redress
they'll never actually receive the
justice and possibly even the protection
afterwards that they deserve from that
so we need to assume that it's happening
and put those protection put protection
measures in place and increasingly
call on parties to the conflict to
respect international humanitarian law
and human rights law
and very briefly because we only have a
minute left but i'd not really clocked
the the impact that it can have on
gender-based violence in other countries
uh countries like yemen just explain to
us briefly why what's happening in
ukraine could make life harder for women
in yemen well and in and in other
contexts as well so we know that
there's major impacts on agriculture and
and planting and harvesting um yemen for
example imports 40 of its cereals from
ukraine and russia
yemen is already um is already facing a
food crisis it's been an emergency and
you know we mustn't forget all the other
emergencies happening around the world
and in contexts where people are so
desperate for survival in places like
yemen that can increase um
early marriage so families will not be
able to support families in there in
there
not won't be able to support all members
of women and girls indeed and they get
married off young susie we're going to
have to leave it there but thank you
very much susie mad again from care